and we're live
excellent welcome everybody this is the
wolfram
summer science live coding championship
we have our contestants ready they know
the rules we will uh
show a question which will appear here
for everyone who's watching live
and we will get our answers in we'll
take a look at them and you all get to
vote
what your favorite answer is um
with that being said uh my name is
robert mendelssohn i will be emceeing it
with my co-host jeff c
friedman over there in the captain chair
and uh big thank you to all the staff
who made this possible as well as the
contestants this would be a fun time
i want to clean fight i want a fair
fight should be very interesting and
without any further ado let's get
question number one
okay
question one ball of string pick any
function listed on the documentation
guide page string operations and create
a new function
that re-implements the basic
functionality of the original without
using the original function within your
new function
inception function within your function
okay demonstrate your new function using
the first example
the documentation page for the original
make sure to indicate in a comment or
text cell
which function you chose to reimplement
okay let's take a look at that
documentation page
i would like to see what is on that
documentation page
and you can't click it on the on the
leaderboard it's a trick
you know what it's good because we have
good seo due to the hard working people
at uh well from research and um
we can take a look at oh we're looking
at string operations
string operations very good well look at
all these options that they have to
choose from
amazing and uh let's see well there's a
lot of good ones here
so which of these do you reckon without
without writing any code which do you
think would be the easiest and hardest
to reimplement not without using that
function of course
that's a good question it's really
dependent on your coding style you know
some of these would be pretty low level
to string join might be hard to uh get
around i don't know
i don't know but what what do you reckon
let's see
um uh
well any of the pattern matching stuff
is
oh yeah uh well actually i i was gonna
say pattern matching stuff is hard but
you can always do like string match q
string contains q
whatever to sort of manually invoke
string pattern matching so if you were
doing string
cases um uh you might
uh i'm not sure how how would you do
string cases
maybe you could use string position yeah
hash is probably going to be a pretty
difficult one
oh yeah important export stream is
probably oh definitely
yeah write something to interpret json
although you could go through uh
you could probably go through import and
export byte array um
so just do a string to byte array or
byte array to string
conversion because i mean there's
nowhere in the question does it say you
can't use a
similar function uh that that's
not the function that you're trying to
re-implement you just can't use that one
particular
uh function find something somewhat
adjacent that's a good point
yep no self-reference allowed i'm not
seeing any answers quite yet is that is
that what you're saying as well jesse
yep yeah the i think our contestants um
might just be taking a little while to
evaluate the question
and first one yep it's the first one
first one's always a bit slower that's
fine that's all right nothing wrong with
that it's gotta
gotta get your feet wet and see what's
good here
yeah there's quite a lot of options
though which is nice so there should be
hopefully
interesting number of different
approaches find clusters that would be
pretty tricky in the next two minutes
you can uh implement fine clusters
absolutely yes contact our hr department
or hiring
contact me i'll get the uh finder's fee
i think you know that's uh oh yes yeah
you can get the referrals
flying clusters yeah but um yeah that
would be pretty impressive
so uh robert shall we um
uh shall we try re-implementing one of
these or at least
talking over how we might do so
yeah we don't care about giving hints to
our our contestants we know that they
are
ethically sound and uh and will not
make use of of such an unfair advantage
yeah although
we could maybe pick a weird one that
people want to do anyways but yeah
is there one that that jumped out to you
let's see
um well now now i'm wondering characters
how would you re-implement characters
without doing characters maybe um
maybe something with string cases yeah
you know what you could do
i i got this one actually sorry if
you're working on this um
i think you could just do uh string
split
ah tricky and then if you give it an
argument of
something blank i think that does that
there you go you got it okay
nobody steal that if you do steal it we
will definitely know
i will know yeah it's a copyright you'll
you know take you to court you know it's
still my code
mm-hmm so from original
um what's it called
let's see so sort an alphabetic sort
what is remind me what is the difference
between the two
or should we we can check i bet there's
a uh there's a set
i think sort the default behavior if you
give it a string
uh you know a list of strings oh we just
got a first answer wonderful
congratulations yeah let's
take a look yeah jonah i'll copy it into
a cell phone
all right in fact let me pull this open
now jonah i am concerned may not have uh
may not have noticed one of the
conditions uh
of the question oh um appears to be
using the word
in the yes the the so you're
re-implementing the function
let's see so yeah you're re-implementing
the function string join but you are not
allowed to use the function string join
in re-implementing the function string
join
um now so let's see so
oh we've got a we've got another one
from we've got another
one from jonah oh and we got
we also have an entry from matthew good
job
i see you changed your name as well
wonderful
yeah good um so let's see okay so this
is uh
jonah's redemption good string length uh
word character's length see it doesn't
use length so nice
yep um can't get simpler than that
excellent
good okay accepted i i should maybe
write that down that that's an accepted
answer
yeah you can just put if you just put
like the section cells in between with
the
subsection with the name much better
idea jonah
cool and maybe get rid of the string
join
uh since i assume jonah's second answer
is preempted or
whatever uh overwritten yes yes and we
will we'll give you that one
first one no problem all right cool
we've got an answer from matthew
let's take a look oh and just to clarify
our scoring
uh paradigm these are not scores this is
just the order in which we've gotten
answers and once we have
five i believe we will close the
question and put the names up
on the twitch poll for uh audience
members on twitch to vote on vote on
your favorite answer and the um
first place will get uh five points
second place gets
four points third place gets three
points
and uh fourth and fifth place
both get two points is that right scott
did i mess that up or is that uh
i think that's it sorry distracted for a
second four three two one one
four three two one one that sounds
better that makes more sense
see i don't even know how we do scores
interestingly matthew is also
re-implementing string lengths
ah interesting has this curious message
it's an interesting interpretation
on a common theme of hello world and
uses the string to bite array which is
curious
yeah that's an interesting uh function
to use well if you think
if you think about it it's very it's
similar to uh to characters
um but i think it's not exactly the same
so what if you can you try oh yeah go
ahead and say that uh try sticking in
the um
uh one of the uh test strings um first
for string length try putting in like
some unicode character like
i'm not sure how to get um like an alpha
or something i always mess this up if
you
like that right yeah that might still be
in in
ascii but oh yeah there we go okay so
that became 14.
yeah it counted as two so because string
to byte array by default um
encodes the string as utf-8 and in utf-8
that's
uh because the whole point is to is to
represent more than 256 characters
using a 256 um
alphabet so to speak you have 256 uh
possible
um numbers in one bite so uh utf-8
um uh is going to encode i believe
uh characters above 127 i think
as uh as two or more bytes so it's not a
perfect re-implementation of
of string length but it's it's pretty
good uh i'll counter that's good
yes i certainly think it qualifies it's
kind of neat that it has that behavior
though
you know it's kind of a non-trivial yeah
it's it's kind of its own thing it's
like utf-8 string length
so this is a string reverse so let's
just try it with a slightly different
one
okay seems to work what are the let's
see how this works so we get
string part the table of string part
oh calling the negative industry and i
think we have five solutions now i've
just been eyeing the um
the thing um we have rule
so what do you think shall we shall we
close the question
we just got four because we've got two
from jonah uh
oh is that okay i count five excluding
jonah's first one
let's let's go through this let's figure
out okay so we have
two from jonah fine matthew
two from jonah two from matthew or two
from assad and two from rule
so we're still at four people i see yeah
and i think there are two copies maybe
of assad's maybe assad corrected
um uh has a correction in his second
or he's just a couple different ones
which is neat yeah so okay
um yeah so string reverse this is good
just kind of
going using table to go through the
different steps through the different uh
parts of uh the string and then um
and assad asks us to use his second
answer so let's grab that one
let's see where we have faith in you
aside that there's a good reason for
that
i think this is the second oh no is it
no let's take a look
what's the difference between the code
well i think the difference may be
between uh
maybe the um uh that's that's rules i
believe
i think the difference in assad's is in
the the uh
the test string
that he tests it with oh oh that's
that's cute i like that that's good um
kudos for that see it's copping over
weird okay
but make sure you're selecting the cell
brackets i guess
you know what that's actually exactly
the problem i'm glad to have you here
jesse
look at this no problem someone asks
someone asks is he on the bridge of the
enterprise i assume they are referring
to me because i'm the only
one here who is on the bridge of the
enterprise i am nobody else's
that's your answer you're welcome uh
let's see what is this
which one is this meant to imitate um
hmm rule uh which which function
are you trying to split i guess it is
string split or
or characters um
rule it would be uh oh okay
what was it i made a mistake sorry okay
okay no problem and it would be good if
you um write your code in the format of
a function
uh so that it can be sorted that it's
right it's just the same as the uh
function that you're that you're
re-implementing so that's okay you can
go ahead and resubmit another when you
you have that
so back to sort an alphabetic sort yeah
i was i can't remember what the
difference is it might say on the page
for alphabetic sort
yeah and so i even when i need to sort
strings i've been using sort
and my understanding is the default
behavior is if you give it a bunch of
strings it'll do it in alphabetical
order
but i wonder what alphabetic sort so
it's just maybe a more explicit version
of that
it's nice it makes the code more
readable i guess yeah can are there any
examples that compare it with sort maybe
under properties and relations
yeah good question ah see alphabetical
order
it's kerosene you've got to specify
okay so you can you can that's cool you
can customize the case ordering i still
don't know if it is
if in default behavior it's identical to
sort
um or not
so we have a solution from ed
wonderful
okay okay and i want to give rule a
chance to um
uh uh uh to give a
a function fixed function version of of
his uh sure
oh this is a neat bit of code look at
this so
what ed has done this is this is clever
um
is to get the character codes for the
string subtract 32 which shifts it into
the
ascii i guess that's capital uh and then
reinterpret it
that's a nice that's a short little bit
of code now i'm wondering what
why is it 32 and not 26. i don't
remember what is between
uppercase and lowercase letters in the
in the
ascii uh sd i guess characters
in fact let us add a z in here and then
we can probably okay so what is from
character code that's the that's the
lowercase though we want to see the um
what's after uppercase i think
you could maybe an easier way would be
like mapping it over a range mapping
from character code
yeah table um
so say from 60 to 100
and then yeah just yeah from character
code of x i guess
x
but the um now we're looking at oh wait
wait is this the
oh so is lower case first you know
it's a good question okay so let's see
what we got okay so uppercase appears to
be first
oh and then oh yeah there it is so let's
see what is it it's
a square bracket slash um another square
bracket
carrot underscore i think and back
underscore backtick
and then it goes okay cool okay and i
think we have a
solution from rule now do indeed so
let's copy that back here
and what do we have two uppercase
get the characters map position of to
lowercase flatten
alphabet spanish index yeah what is that
what is going on here
okay so let's see if i have no idea hold
on
let's see if it works so with the
addition of
i don't know if string joint has to does
that have to be there no it's good
so um
oh curious looking look at the
unexpected behavior how would you even
pronounce that how do you pronounce an
na without a
vowel after it i don't know i don't uh
don't speak spanish better minds than me
uh have thought long about this question
um but i wonder how much this alpha
spanish index character thing is having
to do with it but it's a neat answer
um yeah it is an answer it seems to work
in some cases so fine we'll take it
yep i think we've got our five so i'm
going to close the question if that's
all right with you robert
it's perfectly all right with me
excellent okay time is up and the
question is closed
so we've got our five names and
um uh avery the best person ever is
going to
as i was saying that he put the poll up
on twitter oh look at this
and the poll is up and the time is
rapidly decreasing we have one vote in
forever yes and i believe you have
uh two minutes to vote is it two minutes
maybe that looks more like one minute
you have two votes oh jonah just gotta
find out nice
okay and let's take a look at actually
what the uh okay we've got two minutes
according to avery
for for everybody on twitch to vote and
if you are on youtube
and you are confused because you don't
know how to vote i believe you have to
go to the stephen wolfram twitch channel
uh and watch on twitch instead in order
to
vote for your favorite contestants
favorite solutions rather indeed oh and
you want to maybe uh uncollapse those
cells so we can see their solutions
so if anyone yeah wants to see
our own kind of code ramblings in there
as well i probably should segment that
out but
yeah so yeah we've got let's see so ed
um
yeah ed had a beautifully concise uh
very nice
short little thing yeah using although i
will i will note it's not a function
but uh i'll i'll let ed pass on
that um for now
ed um and then let's see string reverse
that's cool so table and then for each
each um
each uh character in the string we're
replacing it with the character that is
the same distance from the end of the
string instead of the front yeah that's
good
and uh matthew strange utf-8
string length that's what it is but
that's a that could be useful
um that's it that's a potentially useful
thing there isn't a built-in function
for that
i will point out so that's curious
actually that's an interesting point
and uh finally we have jonah with uh
characters and then links yes
also very nice very nice and concise and
ed ed is in the lead
um we have one point over jonah and
we've got a couple seconds remaining
and it's gone to uh it's gone to ed
it goes to head in second place jonah
then matthew saw it and roll
so wonderful um take a look at the
leaderboard
there we go cool excellent okay
that was fast scott you did that way
faster than me
the leaderboard that is uh i realized
that while i'm just
sitting there watching the numbers
they're not changing that fast and i can
enter the names and change the rankings
if needed
see that is what we in the computer
programming world call optimization you
optimized
my algorithm for uh for inputting
scores into the leaderboard
congratulations scott
you get to do this for every competition
in the future going forward
i'm out i just sprained my ankle so i'm
going to have to withdraw myself from
helping out
oh you have one of those ankle keyboards
yep
okay i haven't heard of an ankle
keyboard where do you where do you get
those and how does it work because
in the ankle keyboard store that makes
sense so i have a question
yes we've got a question the function uh
has to work for the first example
um yes does it say that uh it's yes it
says it has to work for the first
example on the documentation page
does one of these not we probably didn't
test it properly we probably did not
um well it actually doesn't say it has
to it just says demonstrate it
and the people have spoken so we are a
we are a uh
a direct democracy here it didn't work
for the romans but it's working for us
because we're the wolf from summer
school so we are a direct democracy the
will of the people is our will and the
will of the people is that ed wins
to be fair i i like liked ed's answer
the best but
it only works if you use lowercase
letters if you use anything else
it just fails because it's shifting by
32 so if you use like an uppercase
letter
well in in this case um uh beauty
beauty trump's function apparently
according to our live stream viewers
and they are who matter
speaking of which they i'm i'm hearing
from them they want the next question
okay next question let's see next
question is going up
now
oh i think i just clicked the button for
the first question again hold on
i knew they shouldn't have put me in
trick question it's the same question
okay there we go question two you should
be getting that now ah
a whole new dimension define a function
plot4d or list plot4d and show an
example of its use
that's crazy plot4d what is a
four-dimensional plot
i mean if you think about it we already
have um uh well maybe i shouldn't give
it away but a possible solution is to
think about what 3d plotting functions
we already have
already exist in the wolfram language
and which of them can be in a sense
considered to be a four-dimensional plot
but
maybe for now we could take a look at
the documentation pages for the
2d and 3d and 1d plotting functions
1d you know it's a good open-ended
question where there's definitely a lot
of different possible answers and it's
pretty creative 4d kind of stuff so
we'll see what people
end up saying for it and in a sense in a
sense you only need to add two of the
existing functions together
uh plot uh like 2d plot plus 2d plot
equals 4d
so maybe that's a way to do it or 3d
plus 1d
there is indeed a person working on four
dimensional visualizations something a
bit more complex than what we're talking
about here but
that'll be interesting it's a cool
project that i look forward to seeing
what goes on with it but
y'all are probably familiar with these
beautiful functions we have for
visualizing things
and then if you were there good oh now
you know you can go ahead robert
if you were there for the michael
foltalk we were asking him about what
his favorite function was and
it was plot all the functions we have it
says uses it most etc but and if you're
on the live stream you're envious that
you were not in the michael foal talk
probably um but that may be published on
youtube at some point
or not i don't know i think we might
actually run into some copyright issues
with that but he uh doesn't know is an
astronaut legit astronaut he even had
the blue jumpsuit when he gave his talk
and
was on board the uh soviet space station
when it
almost was destroyed so very very crazy
cool talk
awesome and that is why everybody who's
watching the live stream right now and
is not
part of the wolfram uh summer school
should apply next year to attend the
wolf from summer school
because we have lots of great guest
speakers and you don't want to miss out
on astronauts we had two astronauts this
year
isn't that crazy yeah it's two
astronauts that's very fortunate
that is out of this world i think that
is indeed
out of this world except i think they
were on earth for the uh for their
for their talks i think we're in moscow
and wherever michael was somewhere in
england england
yeah england um you know very
international crowd i suppose
so we have nationals yeah so we've got
plot which plots a um
plots of function uh and then a list
plot so list and then list plot which uh
takes a list i believe that's not on the
stage
the discretized version yeah i think
this is for mostly for
you know yeah these are continuous
functions yeah
or ideally they would be but well that
looks like it might not be but
um uh here's the discrete function
visualization yeah
there's list one ah there we go some of
these are just so beautiful i
the areas i operate and are not always
able to use these but you know just
really great
i always wonder how do they choose the
default colors what how much
how much effort and thought goes into
picking the uh default colors and color
functions
uh for these i bet i bet there's a ton
of effort into a lot of these things
yeah you know i i wonder how
there must be so many meta algorithms
for visualizing things i
i'm really curious to learn more about
that works but it's great that you don't
have to that just works
without having to think about it um
let's see what we have here so
yeah a lot of good stuff
i kind of wonder then how do you
visualize 5d or 6d kind of stuff
is it true that if someone if a
contestant for instance gives us an
answer that visualizes data in 5d
that they have succeeded in visualizing
in 4d as well or not so much
uh well a as long as their function is
called list plot 4d
um in principle at least whatever it
does does not matter
all that matters is the opinion of our
esteemed live stream
audience on whether that
solution correctly satisfies the uh
constraints of the question
it's up to the mob you know to determine
uh
oh look at this wolfram research has
succumbed to mob rule
yes it's been 30 years coming
33 i think it's 33 wow third of the
century it's amazing
wow yes third of a century rounded down
yes you know i guess uh was in three
months it'll be
exactly one third of the century that's
alright
yeah okay cool are we gonna celebrate
that
we should i think that did i don't know
what the um appropriate thing
would be to do but uh that's quite a
milestone and the average business
doesn't last five years
you know really amazing okay yeah
so let's can we take a look at um uh
some of these uh the list plot
i know you were showing some already but
like list plot um uh 3d
this point plot yeah let's point 3d is a
new one in 12.3 if i'm not no no it's
not this point 3d ah this line
plot 3d is the new it did say new it was
new in something
updated um yeah but there's um list line
plot
3ds is the new one i'm not mistaken so
i was very excited for this i like to
plot kind of some
you know if you want to plot the
trajectory of something etc there was
only kind of a
package way to do that by having you
know creating these objects that
happen to line up the points but this is
a wonderful function
wow look at that that's neat copy that
code
take a look at that
let's see any any uh solutions yet no i
don't see any yet
it's a tough one huh people are yeah i
wonder what approaches they're going to
take
do you have any ideas how would you do a
four dimensional plot
um yeah so i'll tell you initially what
i was thinking about
is is about using color you know so
using color or density
so this already does 4d so this would be
bad oh wow
because so it's a 3d thing
right except i need the data of course
um and
you know it's interesting because this
this can work in some cases like in this
case where
you most of your data points are at the
edges but if they were internal it could
be obfuscated you're you know playing
with either the color or opacity to
represent the fourth dimension
um so this is good in some applications
i think
but um you know if you have sparse data
and color
yeah or opacity is probably a good
choice the question is what happens if
you have very dense data and it's not
entirely clear what to do so be curious
to see what people say
oh my i'm at six percent wow
are people nervously looking at that we
are we all are
i don't understand what the deal is here
it's plugged in etc
very sad it's just the the incredible
power consumption of
of live coding commentary yes
you know the to my speech is so
information rich that to compress it is
almost impossible
exactly yep yeah you've got zoom running
um yeah
in mathematics and it is not happy
zoom's probably running at 150
cpu right now so it's it is is using
more power than can be can be conveyed
into the computer
is that compression or what do you what
would you think that would be
uh yeah i think it's it's compression
and encoding your video
into whatever compressed form probably
not very compressed but
compressed form is used uh by zoom
yeah it is not liking that not liking
this
so like this plot that we've got here
this is already
in a sense 4d is it not because we've
got our three dimensions of space and
one dimension of color
well so it's a good question so i think
in this case the um
the the color i think is
maps onto the same thing being displayed
but if it was mapping onto something
else it certainly would be 40 i think
oh and oh yeah you're saying you can't
display any arbitrary point
at as a given color okay yeah i see
that's why you were mentioning the
density uh
density plot function right that if if
you could make it an arbitrary value
i'm sure you could um then you would
have a 40 but yeah
very nice so then i suppose list point
plot 3d which i believe we had maybe you
just showed that
uh that can display arbitrary points um
do we have a list we have a list point
cloud 3d yes um that can display
arbitrary uh arbitrary points at
arbitrary locations with arbitrary
colors so
yes that four dimensions uh i think it
is up to our audience
but i'd say it probably is
so here the colors are per series so
we've got our sign
in the center that's that's blue and
then the cosine
uh and wait there are
there are only three why are there uh
oh because it's a table of this oh okay
oh yeah it's a table of that over four
so okay my bad yeah because this is this
is the xyz coordinates
right right right i got it iterated cool
okay that makes sense yeah yeah so
you're right it's a series but if
i mean it could be without too much
difficulty with it with a color function
or something you could
use data to map on it it's interesting
it's pretty easy to see what's going on
with the points here because they're
pretty well um
you know uh spaced i guess just space
enough to see it's
more obvious with this although yeah
good do we have a um
oh we got one as you as you spoke oh and
your battery i think it just went up one
percent from flat
first oh okay all of those for all of
those uh robert's battery fans in the
audience who are
keeping keeping close tabs on robert's
battery level we've got live color
commentary on
robert mendelsohn's battery charge level
you know it's uh we had to up the stakes
and we had to kind of
increase the you know nervousness of the
audience like you know james bond movie
the yeah clock is ticking down
yeah that battery level that's actually
not real scott has a slider on his desk
that's linked directly to your
battery level display in the um in the
toolbar and scott is just jiggling that
up and down
uh to give us plot basically
so yeah you might want to reevaluate
that because the dynamic does not come
over the over the pipe
over the magical that's the mechanism
that we're using to
collect answers so we appear to have a
list plot 4d
and it's interesting it takes a single
value
very interesting because it's not a list
but it looks like maybe he generates a
list using this function which
good good for you oh we have a second
solution as well and nowhere does it say
that nowhere do we say anything about
what your function plot4d or list
plot4d must do whatever it must be
called
one of those names and i'll say we're
case insensitive just
just to be nice um so this one's okay
so this is curious you know so
it's a list plot 3d it looks like let's
point out 3d
but it is moving it's using time as the
fourth short dimension of time
visualizing some weight or something so
this is nice yeah this is a
pretty standard approach but i think the
result is nice and i like to use the
list animate function
a lot of people uh are maybe not aware
of that but church turing thesis says
that your battery
is their favorite participant
i will say i've looked at both of the
submissions and they go in two very
different directions and i thoroughly
enjoy
both of them that's awesome let's see
what's the second one
you're about to copy them it's from
assad except
church turing thesis is uh well i don't
know maybe
maybe the relationship between the
person behind that username and the
their real name is not
public knowledge so i will i will not
say what avery just told me but that's
someone at the summer school yeah i see
yeah when i watch the live streams i see
uh that username quite frequently
commenting interesting stuff
so um i don't know if they're an insider
i don't want to help them if they aren't
now are they commenting interesting
stuff on the live streams in which they
themselves are a participant
i don't know i i'm not aware i have
questions of the uh
oh it's in the okay interesting that
actually makes a lot of sense
i will not not disclose who it is but uh
very cool
look at this okay so assad's thing is to
make a plot of
4d which is very literal but it's
creative and um yeah i mean it satisfies
it is not a function i will point out
but um
i'm impressed with this because they had
to sit here and figure out what points
to use to draw yeah and i like the
i like the is it the um uh the d
that is that uh those those two uh
equations or functions that are being
plotted yeah does that that seems like a
half of a sphere you know are there two
of them they're identical
oh no one's minus one's plus yes so they
have to do
the top bit is one in the box oh yeah
right they they both they break at three
yeah this is a you know that's
impressive
yeah no i like this answer i'm impressed
they were to do this in
such a short time this is it this isn't
a
oh answer okay yes
uh robert we're losing your audio a
little bit
um
oh sorry i went to unmute myself and
accidentally muted jesse
thanks scott i i'll try not to take it
personally
i mean i know so many people want to
mute me
good
yeah an interesting approach by both i
wonder you know
i guess you know to come up with this
certain stuff you could make an
arbitrary
you know write out arbitrary stuff like
this yeah plot plot arbitrary dimensions
you could um what's it called uh have
different kind of fonts
etc i guess as well usually it's a
geometrical one
here's a question for a function such as
this one that does the same thing as
this
plot plot nd that plots the the
number n and then the letter d what is
the maximum
n that you could use and like still have
it work and fit within memory and return
a result
instead of it's crashing because it uses
too much memory i don't know it has
something to do with
probably mostly with the number of
digits in n but it also has to do with
the complexity of the digits the
the the um that's true characters in
them so
because obviously the curves the curves
have it seems a lot more complexity than
you know the more linear kind of
computer
looks like we have a third solution in
from ed
who's currently in first place all right
let's run it oh i like the colors on
this already
oh and we have a uh fourth one from
jonah
wonderful oh look at this
oh pretty i know i like the pretty
colors you know i'm easy to please with
that
and here yeah this is an example of
using a custom color function so ed has
explicitly specified that each point
should be colored by its um
its rgb color value uh so taking x y and
z to be
uh red green and blue uh so respectively
so i think this is what we were talking
about isn't it it's it's 3d plus color
oh no it's it's time as well okay so i
guess the
it's 3d but it appears as though it's
actual height is being represented by
the color
yeah yeah i think you're i think you're
right so uh the the um
i guess the time is just for just for
show
but you know i think this is a better
answer than yeah what i was talking
about because otherwise it would just
change the bulk color of everything
according to time right so
yeah good answer and uh i like the
explicit color function then it's a
pretty good
very nice now you could um i was going
to say you could use rgb color as that
color function but i actually don't know
because um
the color function it plot 3d might give
more than three arguments
and we really only want the first three
arguments uh depending on the function
the color function syntax that it gives
the
function that you give is varies so oh
like whether you you know don't need
this function stuff you can use rgb here
yeah we can try that that's that's
curious side um
let's see so we have a fourth answer
from
jonah yeah which i will post and then
let's real quick just i think i'm just
curious whether this will work if you
um
just get rid of this oh and i just know
i noticed that um
is that ed's ed is using set instead of
set delayed
um to define this oh yeah
well okay that's interesting ed use set
instead of set delay to define this
function i suspect that's just a simple
typo but it happens to sort of work
because it is returning
what is it returning where um
oh so okay the input values x y and z
are not actually used um
the they're discarded and then the it's
uh it's a fixed
ranges zero to three zero to three and
negative one to one so
yeah um it went does this qualify
technically speaking as a function
even though it ignores its inputs um i
mean even if it ignored its inputs it
would still be a function but
is using set instead of set delay is it
still a function i'm not sure
but we'll we'll allow it we'll assume
that that's just a
simple typo missing the uh the colon on
there it achieves its objective in my
opinion indeed
it returns it returns a a a nice
visualization
apologies i i can update that i wasn't
sure how functional the function
actually had to be
but uh no worries we'll let you through
on this one it clearly
clearly it's a good faith submission
that's what we're looking for here
at the wolfram summer school live coding
competition 2021. i just read that off
the leaderboard i don't remember what it
is
um good faith answers that's what we're
looking for
i'm seeing an issue with the um hmm with
this but i
it could very well be the fact that
maybe i've already defined plot4d let me
write it again yeah that is for
everything
yeah is that a decent solution
yeah i do yeah you could do clear all of
plot4d or something
you still there robert
yep okay yeah i can i can hear you can
you hear me
yes i can hear you now okay well good
news it's gone up to six
so you know we're we're doing great yeah
so let's try this got a second wind
your battery apparently yeah okay so
that's still nothing so can we figure
out what is this trying to do
it's a little opaque we've got the um
definition of a function
and then we're defining
what is that second thing with x rst etc
what exactly
is that word um well it's it's set of a
list so we're
saying x of r s t equals r
sine s cos times cos cosine t
um but it's a just an immediate set it's
set not set delayed so
uh does that matter in this case um
i would think it might let's see what
the but oh but it works in the in the
output it does return
those are at least returning but
maybe um if jonah if you're able to
maybe clean this up um
so that it does uh whatever you're
you're
expecting and doesn't define on any
sorry it doesn't depend on any like
predefined
things uh that would be awesome just let
it let us know
i mean it's still hey it satisfies the
the uh the constraints of the question
which are very broad just to find a
function plot 4d
and that is what jonah did so
indeed the um we never asked for the
function to work
absolutely yep that's intentional yep
or not it's actually not intentional at
all i wrote the questions that was not
intentional
it was intentional it has something to
do with the arguments here that they
probably know
yeah it looks like they have to they
have to be
yeah there's kind of a uh a um
[Music]
like conflicting expectations here
plot4d was expecting
explicit arguments x of rst and we're
giving it explicit arguments
but x of rsd also have replica
definitions assigned to them so they
they get transformed into something else
before they reach the function
oh has he done it has robert mendelsohn
cracked
the solution well we depends on what it
originally did depends on what it's
supposed to do
maybe that's what it's supposed to do
it's so interesting to see how other
people write wolf in language code you
know i
don't work on a team that has like a
particular linting or kind of way that
they do things and
um so it's sort of home brew in whatever
way you like it and when you read other
people's code you see what functions
they like to go do and
you know i thought about one point about
making like a wolfram language
personality test
right like you know submit you know your
answer to this kind of programming
question and will tell you you know
are you more of a person person do you
prefer to use
you know part versus kind of associate
or you know list versus associations
versus data sets and
there's definitely multiple flavors of
wolfram language that would be awesome
the wolfram language
uh personality test i would love to see
that what do you think the dimensions of
that would be
what do you think the different kind of
uh
that's a good question yeah would it be
like a four dimensional thing like uh
mbti um are there can we perhaps we
could
perhaps we could define it using the
wolfram language we could set any number
of dimensions and then do a dimension
reduction using the dimension reduce
function
to reduce those to a defined set of of
four or whatever
uh dimensions that uh that characterize
you as a a wolf and language
uh programmer look at the answers do
some kind of feature space plot and then
see what unites those
someone in twitch chat says the uh
composition versus
uh our uh composition versus right
composition holy war
i am firmly on the side of right
composition
except for when the um uh when the the
first
argument is not so not composition
something else i think that reads better
otherwise
i'm on the right composition side that's
prefix versus postfix notation or
something different
no something different they um related
in a sense composition and right
composition are the
functional forms of prefix and post-fix
notation so i think i think that's an
that's a
roughly accurate statement so this what
we're seeing okay so that's
yeah that's something a little different
that's um yeah yeah you can take a look
at the um
location reverse polish notation and
such or
nothing to do with that yeah so this is
the notion of of composing functions
before they are applied to a value
um and it just composition does it in
one direction right composition does it
in the other direction
uh just like post prefix and postfix
notation but they're
but they're different from from prefix
and fix because these are just uh
composing functions
yeah that's a good example interesting
these are combinators i i was messing
around that i
i've definitely used this yeah these are
these are great things um
these are great uh it's great to get to
know these and use these in your code
because it can make a lot of a lot of
things that you do like much
neater and tidier uh if you write them
as as compositions of
of functions and pure functions and and
and whatnot
so let's see any other no no other uh
solutions yet
um maybe give them another minute or so
for um
jonah to update his code or for one of
the other guys to
fully submit sure we'll give you all
until robert can you show the uh
leaderboard for a sec
we will give you all until i'm going to
say 4 50.
a minute and 15 seconds for free
and then we'll continue um yeah you know
it's interesting because
some of the best well from language code
can you move the notebook just south a
little bit so the number still shows up
good framing um some of the tightest
code i've seen excellent composition
ends up looking like data you know uh
import you know do something
you know
and then some kind of you know
visualization
but now here's the thing what if you
wanted to do what if data were a
list of things you wanted to import and
you wanted to do import and then do
something and then another thing and
then
visualization on each element of those
lists
of the each element of that list um
that's tricky to do here with with your
um
uh your your postfix notation but you
could do
a composition or right composition of
those four functions import then do
something then another thing that
visualization
and that composition or right
composition represents
uh all those functions like bundled
together in sequence as a
sort of like a pre-composed function and
then you can map that
composition or right composition over
each uh each element in your list
and then you've got your you got your
results so the the holy war
is just basically which direction do you
want to write those functions in when
you're um
when you're writing your composition or
right composition expression
yeah good and i'm with you that whatever
makes it kind of the most clearer
probably be the winner clarity very
important
we've got a uh not quite in time but
we'll allow it um we've got in the uh
we've got one more solution from
uh any
sorry i'm i'm sorry i am afraid i'm
going to mess up
uh pronunciation uh on that name is that
uber
okay oh wow hole in one um you should
also regrab jonah because he resubmitted
and it works this time
ah okay jonah did resubmit i missed that
then um
cool i'm getting a beach ball here do
you uh know what to do
oh no not sure um
is that uh let's see
uh we could we could switch over to me
for now if you like and um
and we can uh uh you can maybe restart
okay i'm just typing okay that was we
had rule assad
and who was third i'm sorry i missed i'm
i'm copying over the
ed we had ed is third and fourth is
jonah and then ubud
yeah of course the order here doesn't
matter i was just making sure i had the
right people
okay so i will share now one second
okay um
so i'll copy over uh from here i'll grab
and i see some uh yeah matthews were i'm
afraid after
after the cutoff and also after we had
five i believe
so um we can only put weird technical
limitation we can only put five
oops uh five in the poll
uh so here sorry let me grab
uber does it was uh the battery we're
now at eight percent
so it's trending upwards yeah they're
not saying it let's start going back
down again
but um okay so let's see what do we have
what do we have here what do you make of
this
wow look at that that is that's very
interesting
can you can you rotate that uh yeah it
looks like it's
look at that nice so what's the what is
the fourth dimension we're seeing here
um what do you think is it the fact that
the lines that the points are connected
well no it's just that that would just
be a line
line plot there um
there might not be one i don't know i
mean if i'm trying to be very creative
you could say the
i think that i don't know if it's
pronounced correctly please correct me
in the chat but the
more a patterns when you have all those
kind of intersecting things and
maybe maybe that could be considered
another layer of data to make for
but i'm not certain um
okay um let's come back up and running
which is good
so well remember back down to six
percent oh no oh no
you've lost one um okay so well
i remember really we made no we made no
prescription about what the function
must do only that it must be called
actually this isn't a function but we'll
pretend it's a function that's called
either plot for d or list plot for d
oh that's nice i like this angle here
you see that perspective effect
oh yeah very nice to do some art
with that of some some variety okay and
then jonah's
uh let me grab that from the chat here
okay
let's see ah there we go
take a look at that it's a pumpkin no
it's a sphere
it's a pumpkin when it's still um when
it's doing the low resolution cloth now
it's a sphere
um and the dimension
it looks like you look very you look
closely
yeah something's changing yeah the scale
on the
scale is changing which makes sense
because r is the parameter you're
manipulating right
so ah yes so i guess so is is the
hmm so is this
trying to think in what dimensions in
what sense is this four-dimensional
um or maybe it isn't again we didn't say
it has to
has to be four-dimensional um it's a 3d
object that you're allowed to
manipulate a parameter yeah since you're
moving it in time by sliding yeah there
you go
yeah you've got the time again yeah okay
that makes sense it's kind of like i
guess it's like a
maybe like a polar coordinate or
spherical coordinate plot where the
fourth dimension is time
i don't know if that's the right way to
think about it but hey it's it's uh
we've got something uh robert are you
able to uh are you ready to share i i am
indeed ready to share
okay cool so uh you should probably copy
jonas jonas and uh
um stuff over so we have it all
consolidated
and go ahead okay so we're back
we're back thank you i'm we're having
some problems at the studio
and by studio i mean my apartment
so um it's not a studio except there's
this lighting which
i guess makes uh makes my face look very
shiny
so i promise it's a normal level of
shininess but um
all right so it's at one end of the
scale is a studio and the other end is a
studio apartment and yours is
in the middle that's right i assume not
is it a studio apartment
um i'm i'm very proud to say that it's a
one bedroom
so uh just one you know on that
continuum okay it is not at the forex
trade right
okay so it's not it is neither a studio
nor a studio apartment but really
anything could be a studio if you call
it a studio
that's true okay so um yeah let's uh
let's show just bring up the uh the um
solutions and i think avery you can you
can put up the uh
the poll thank you um gives me a good
idea though you could tell people that
you know you're at the studio art studio
or you know recording studio and it
could just be your studio apartment
and robert could you bring up your
notebook with the solution so that
anyone who missed them can uh can see
yes um so let's go through some of these
um yeah and uh maybe copy jonas and uber
does over
yes
my pleasure thank you you know what i'll
have to get the um
my chat session going sorry just a
second
cool um but yeah there's this is rules
answer
um which it's nice manipulate which
actually not manipulate excuse me it's a
list animate it's a function that i've
actually learned about decently recently
and i really like it and has this rather
spirited ways going through it
it's pretty cool looking so good job
role
we have an answer from assad can i have
a very um oh let's go
oh assad is uh pulling in first with
this
very good twitch chat likes that this 4d
thing
it's creative it's not what i would have
expected which is always fun
and i don't know how you figure out what
points i don't know if you had to write
this down with paper or something but
i'm impressed you're able to get these
points
and um even had to split this kind of
hemispherical part of the d
all right so that's um good work it
reminds me of those
famous person curves on wolfram alphabet
absolutely yes makes homer simpson or
something like that
yeah in fact we might even do that
that's a lot of fun
is there actually there's even a wolfram
curve let's do that
or there better be obligatory yes there
definitely is
better let's see this should be fun
um okay so what properties does it have
because i want to see the plot of it
so many properties here this is amazing
okay and we've got
um we're uh paul is almost complete
and looks like assad is in the lead
okay let's see uh eight votes and wow
who we have oh assad you have one assad
gets it
very good followed by rule and jonah
tied for second and
we have and we have a a uh a canine
appearance on assad's webcam uh right
now i'm not sure if you guys
can see that assad maybe if you um yes
you are visible on the stream
we have a canine appearance live
um is it or maybe is that assad and the
human behind uh
behind him or her is i
i don't know interpreter
it's a very creative answer you know it
wouldn't be surprising if it was just a
very
intricate 29 to you whoever you are do
you interpret the dog's barks into code
well from language code is there like a
defined
translation
say three barks for yes um
but we have a very interesting oh there
it is oh
that's good um we have a very
interesting project going on
interpreting uh
whale sounds very interesting
um they're actually very sophisticated
so if you're with the summer school you
should definitely check out the
presentation it's gonna be a very
interesting one so
good okay so uh there you have it let's
check the leaderboard overall
uh we have jonah and first got a
respectable three points in each
question
followed closely by ed and assad who are
tied uh for second presently uh rule
just one point behind them
and then we have matthew and ovidos so
good good this is a
neck and neck so it's anybody's game at
this point
um so very exciting and i think that if
people are ready we could go on to the
next question
yeah but before then um i think we
should we have our special video
i think we should roll our oh yes our
interstitial video
so uh brandon let's let's do the thing
yeah video thing thank you
and it is happening i see it happening
next thing is thinging
now i don't know if they can still hear
us they can still hear us then hi
if not then ignore what i just said
um okay are we are we done with the
video
and we're back and we're back and we're
back yeah how
how energetic is that video i mean you
know you think we're easy
you're coming to the ufc where the top
of the ticket you know top of the
fight card uh but it's a wolfram live
coding championship for the whole from
summer science absolutely let's do it
let's roll
for question three questions three our
comments
should be receiving now i can see you
with i as your physical eye write a
function that transforms eyes
from any photo of a face eg change eye
color add sunglasses
make them anime styled etc you can
import image of a non-existent person's
face from this person does not exist.com
and uh there's an image resized thing i
don't know if people in the audience
have heard of this site but it is
actually kind of freaky
um this person does not
exist dot com it's quite a long url
but this person does not exist i think
this is a general adversarial
generalization neural network that is
generating this
in fact degenerative excuse me hey i
know her
every time you refresh it you just get
another one
haunting i don't know can you just can
you tell are these
would you be able to tell the difference
that these are not real people or
absolutely not
never never in a million years i mean
they look more real than real pic
real people like the pictures are really
sharp
um good resolution wow i wonder what
their training set was was it you know
linkedin photos or what did they
do but yeah this is amazing um
i think we added uh gan functionality
the wolfram language
um actually not even 123 we had it
before uh
i have not played around with it but i
it's on my list of things to do
this is nuts that's crazy it's like
they they put the piercing in there i
mean that's amazing whoa
yeah okay and then for legal reasons of
course we we encourage using these uh
these pictures for your solutions
instead of real people actually it
probably doesn't matter but
it's cool i mean why not why not add
some neural networks into the mix
why not add some deep learning buzzwords
to your uh to your answer you know
looking more closely i
i probably could tell this wasn't a real
photo yeah some of the textures there's
some texturing problems
around the glasses well i think you
would only know if you were if someone
asked if someone said this
there's a 50 chance that this this
picture was generated by a
neural network and isn't a real person i
think if it was just presented to you
i don't think you would um i certainly
would never would never uh
guess that it might not be a real person
like i think most people's pupils are
totally round or at least
oblong yeah the eyes feel like a little
little uh unusual there and i'm looking
at really minor details
and i don't know if i can tell but like
this is a pretty good one
i don't know okay so this is now the
wolfram summer school person or not
competition 2021.
yeah um
indeed um let's see i'm sorry i haven't
looked to see if we have an answer yet
not quite
okay and um i i notice our uh
one of our twitch chat um uh audience
members who's the same person i
mentioned before points out uh that the
live coding competition motto is it's
technically esports
it's technically esports it's
technically esports there's e
and it's a competition so it's sports so
you know i personally like to be thought
of as an athlete and uh
you know i sure they give out these
crazy belts
for the wolfram tech conference live
cutting championship yeah we forgot to
mention we forgot to mention you
are a past past champion and you have
completed the time-honored
uh tradition of competing from uh sorry
uh uh
uh moving from competing to commentary
and he's retired i've retired
involuntarily i hung up the shoes
and now you know like a retired boxer i
could just comment to what other people
are doing um and
live vicariously through them but uh you
know i probably won't win an athletic
belt so
it makes me feel like an athlete and
that's what matters right uh
let's see do we have uh no answers quite
yet this is a challenging one
and yeah
so what are some what are some functions
that you think people might um
might make use of in their solutions
here i mean it's pretty open-ended but
there are
i can think of a couple like things like
fine faces
facial features yeah and you know so
people have fairly common proportions
with where their eyes are and so if you
do find faces and kind of go
sort of three-quarters not
three-quarters of the way like
two-thirds of the way up you'll get a
box that goes around their eyes so
i would probably naively try to get you
know you ever see those top secret
photos they have like their eyes
kind of a black bar or something or
blurred but he doesn't even have to be
naive you can um
with i think something like facial
features you can ask where are the eyes
in this in this picture
yeah yeah we've got we've got uh facial
feature recognition
i had not heard of that that's amazing
surprise whoa
see you know every time thing every
night you you learn something new
every day that's the phrase amazing you
know it's like there's
there's always a new feature every time
you want to do this kind of weird niche
thing there's usually a function that
actually does that specific thing
so yeah how would and i mean it's you
might think like how would i do this
what are the
what um what are the low level functions
i might be able to compose together to
approximate an
accurate solution or you can just search
in the documentation and discover that
there is a function that does exactly
what you're trying to do
so what function would extract their
eyes okay so noise
nose points yeah and i think there are
there are probably some examples in here
that would show at least one that shows
look at that look at that eyebrows nose
mouth and now
it's definitely got eyes somewhere
wow there you go yes left left eye and
right eye center
um next table next left eye
wow that is amazing just built into the
language
yeah i promise i'm not getting paid
extra for this pitch
this one's easy just draw a line between
the two and make it thick and then
you've got
um uh covering the eyes or if you want
it to be horizontal you
would maybe it would be a rectangle that
includes both of the eye points in case
the head is at an angle
there are a couple of considerations to
make but you can put circles over it to
go do like
different colorize oh yeah pupils
yeah i could hear was getting a bit
choppy you were speaking in tongues for
a few seconds
he does that sometimes it's a robert
thing i did grow up in texas so
you know there's that but um what's it
called yeah googly eyes
um i'd be very good if people could
paste you could do that pretty easily
you know paste big white circles and
then little black circles and yeah
if you can get them to spin around like
make them
then yes i'm voting for that one i
haven't been voting but if someone does
that i'm voting for that i will create a
twitch account
actually i have one because i watch the
uh the physics project stuff and
i last usually six or seven minutes
until i'm completely lost but
i'm getting a little further good a
little further each time
that's the that's the that's the goal
some of the terminology is amazing
i'm not really certain what zx calculus
is but it sounds really awesome
so z and x the most mysterious
letters i think it comes i think it
comes right after a yw
calculus
and your audio cut out so i didn't hear
you laugh at my hilarious joke
yes i'm sure i'm sure that's what you
were doing right that's what i was doing
and um
i was saying that the zx calculus was
developed many years after the aa
calculus was invented
so sure um it's all chronological um
let's see no answers yet that's all
right uh
justin are having a good time um yeah
don't answer any of these questions
we'll just just let me and robert keep
speaking indefinitely until the end of
time
put like a little squidward nose on
people that would be pretty funny man
i'm gonna have a good time with this
prompt after
after this competition absolutely yeah
man as soon as i want to say something
it's cutting out it's how do you know
when you're cutting out
i'm curious because you start cutting
out it starts getting kind of cheap
and well then maybe it's at my end who
knows now the five percent is
entertaining but
robert devolving into speaking in
tongues and whatnot is definitely
fantastic you know in the spirit of this
uh
uh is it a person or not thing maybe
maybe i should start speaking in tongues
and then you tell me if it's latency
issues or
i'm just actually speaking in tongues
which tongues do you speak in what is
your tongue of choice
you know it's curious i wonder if we
have tongues listed as a language
you just did it again didn't it yeah
unbelievable
bad okay uh just i'm gonna maybe have
you take the heavy for a couple minutes
and hopefully
yeah you can go you can reset your uh
your things your various things
whatever things you might have to reset
good luck
thank you godspeed captain
godspeed engaged along and prosper
excuse me there you go live long and
fast
very good
okay i'll uh take over the share
for tag teaming on the screen sharing
tag team screen share
so i'm curious i want to take a look at
some some more examples
um uh from the documentation
uh for these functions we've got facial
features
let's see so yeah we were just looking
at that on on robert screen so
look not not just age and gender but
emotion
that's interesting i guess yeah that's
trained on some set of people
expressing different emotions i wonder
what what the uh
did someone tag the images based on
emotion or did they ask them to sit in
front of a camera and
look happy look sad look angry um who
knows what was the training process for
uh for that classification system
i wonder for like the feeling stuff how
much it uses
the big stuff like a smile and how much
it uses the eyes
because you can have a fantastic smile
and just dead eyes of like i am not
happy
my mouth says i'm happy but my eyes say
i'm going to murder you
yes well the i mean the examples you got
here and i mean kind of uh
maybe not entirely representative given
as these are all
uh these are all happiness um
let's see so we had nose points i mean
i'll maybe try
writing something real quick here i have
an idea for a way to
uh cheat and make this easy so we've got
eye
points and this might um
i don't know if it has to like download
a neural net the first time i run this
we'll see
it's doing something some of these some
of these functions that are powered by
um
by deep learning uh systems and and
trained neural nets
um are uh
let's see yeah some of these uh they
have to download something
um at the beginning uh like a neural net
uh and then but then here next time i
run it it should be quite fast
uh yeah okay yeah so that's pretty much
instantaneous um
so let's see high points so i was
thinking i might
oh it's multiple points i really just
want the center
of each eye so i center maybe
okay cool so that's that's the two of
those
um maybe let's do highlight image
uh on i i could save these in a variable
okay and then highlight image these this
should just draw points this is just
like what they're doing over here
um oh wait oh that's the center in
between both eyes
not quite what i what i was what i was
looking for i was hoping for each eye so
let's start a new new notebook here i
mean your function could always be to
turn them into a cyclops
it could yeah that's that would be cool
using you could maybe do that using in
painting or something like grab the left
eye
and then uh in paint there's a function
in paint which will like fill in part of
an image based on the background so
in paint over both eyes and then paste
the left eye in the center
oh we have a solution we have a solution
from jonah
let's see this is a pretty nice looking
solution if i do say so myself
um question what is this three yes it
says over there on the leaderboard of
course
um this is very nice
uh so we're we're getting a person who
does not exist
from over here um we are
importing um another image an image of
clip
clip art of cartoon eyes
cool and then we are resizing it to 100
pixels across
getting the eye center just like this
one the point in between both eyes and
then pasting
composing um uh those eyes
over uh over the center of that image
and this is a transparent background so
the background here shows
uh shows through my eyes deceived me or
has somebody done the googly eyes one
successfully not
not quite my condition for uh for voting
was that it has to have a manipulate
that lets me like move the
orb just be animated that moves the
pupils around
that's my condition i may not have
stated that clearly enough but
um that's just for me voting anyone else
who likes this this is pretty nice so
anyone else who likes this
is uh is uh of course free to to vote on
it
okay um so anyways i was
just uh gonna get let's see i think i
want the left eye center and right eye
center
and uh those okay
so grab this
okay there we go um that's uh
uh that is uh the left eye center and
the right eye center so really i just
want the um
uh the values of each of those
associations here i don't care about
which is right and which is left
can i do this okay there now we've got
over each
eye and my trick my idea that i had was
um uh was to uh
just modify the settings of this
um so i could do
what are the options here i was thinking
maybe there's some way to do something
fancier than just a little purple dot
maybe a slightly less evil looking color
as well slightly less evil looking
what what color is less evil than purple
i think purple's a pretty evil color so
i mean i i wouldn't think it would be
that evil it just kind of looks that
evil right now there okay so let's see i
can specify a style if i put it
looks like before this is that right
yeah there we go now it's okay that's
more evil sorry about that
um uh green or cyan is
the complementary color uh to red so it
would
presumably be the least evil um
complementary color in uh complementary
color of light not pigment okay
make them large they're already large so
maybe
i like that that's good that's pretty
that's pretty nice um oh we've got a
second solution
that is similar approach actually to the
first one it looks like
uh that one was ed i believe yes head
okay uh i don't know why that's colored
uh black here oh i bet it's because i
had copied it from the
the uh the thing that we used to send
send the uh
uh send the questions okay so actually
pretty simple oh what do we have here
we looks like
maybe a little bit of a syntax mistake
here where we have this
is actually part of a function called
new eyes that's not used so i think this
is what
had meant to do
okay there we go excellent and here
there's an extra step that we can see
because we're removing background from
the eye image first
it looks like it starts out with some
kind of uh
background might just be white yeah
probably white but if i
move this inspector over it it will tell
me
oh there actually isn't a background um
interesting so maybe the remove
background is
oh no okay it's read it's being
reassigned to here so we overwrote the
original
okay there we go it starts off with a
black background so we have to get rid
of that so that there is a um
uh there's a transparent alpha channel
uh
here so we can overlay it on that image
um okay
cool um uh robert are you
uh ready to take back over or i'm back
you're back robert five percent battery
up to 5 battery still
i think the lowest it's gotten is two or
three and the highest was like maybe
eight or nine
wow it's a it's a real roller coaster
it's a real
emotions sinusoidal kind of thing yeah
well look at this
kind of pointing in um
very good wow so ed has gotten a good
answer oh
so i have two people done um google yes
looks like yeah two
fair uh similar but not exactly the same
uh solutions using
using googly eyes are you are you ready
to uh take back
khan are we doing star trek terminology
that's great i i do not have answers
copied over maybe
for third question if you wouldn't mind
continuing and maybe we can switch over
cool thank you okay yeah are you able to
copy over
copy them over real quick um okay thanks
yeah i have to i have to attend to
something for a second
that's all right i can copy that real
quick you can sure thanks
here i will stop sharing and okay
i can start sharing very good
i know that this there we go episode has
been riveting with the
battery i promise you it's anything but
that for me
uh i don't know what was going on you
think as someone who works in tech i'd
have figured it out by now but uh
some things are just just real deep
mysteries you know
so let's take a look at this um okay so
we have a good answer from jonah
we're copying over now let's take a look
oh look at that oh wonderful okay
clear image important resize it good
then we are going to ah
from the internet get a picture of
someone's googly eyes so good job
um i guess it's a transparent one so
very good
oh they s they then just compose it okay
with the eyes over it that's a nice
answer good job yeah
yeah very impressive um and then let's
see
this is nice uh from ed
man there's nothing like googly eyes
okay okay
and i've just seen i just saw a third
one come in uh again from jonah
and i'm just realizing that we totally
forgot to state
that you're well normally not supposed
to submit multiple
like different answers the same uh to
the same question i mean if
you need to revise a previous answer
that's fine but
super awesome different one than
fairness as well although it is actually
it's
it is similar i think it's also
importing eyes i can't tell
right away what it's doing oh maybe it's
the it's the manipulate that i asked for
maybe jonah satisfied my goals it is
it's both glorifying and horrible all
the best things are
what did cicero say that the the
greatest pleasures in man are close to
disgust something like that i don't know
i didn't read them that carefully um
but oh wow so what is this
i'm excited is it satiating your desire
for me
it is uh googly eyes oh wonderful jonah
has heard my
my request and has has done it how does
this work
let's try it oh okay it's
in oh i think i think jonah found an
animated gif
um of of eyes uh
of whether the people uh the people
moves because they i notice it imports
as a list
which would suggest that the source is
an animated gif because that's how
gifs uh import by default i think
curious it's taking a moment to run
but i can't blame people for that
what is
lh3.googleusercontent.compreps.com
perhaps a
delivery network i yeah
i'd say it's a um it's a cached uh
a cached thumbnail for a search result
on google images
nice makes sense it's clever so
you think an animated gif let's see if
it runs what 97 megabytes is it
oh look at this
so i think jonah has satisfied my
conditions and
jonah gets my vote oh this is one
congratulations good work
yes i can see jonah celebrating
celebratory victory dance
very good wow look at that okay let's
try with another face
wonderful like how
like poorly drawn they are that just
makes it even better frankly
wonderful okay and um
i guess we can wait another minute or
two for another yeah let's give it
another
two minutes maybe we're at 5 22. so
5 25. yeah good
yeah fun good job yeah this is clever
and
you know the code is pretty lightweight
this is a very easy yeah
definitely so so let's see we're getting
the um i centers and then we are adding
10 to each of the
x coordinates oh no we're getting the i
center which is one and then
there's only one of them and then we're
get we're adding 10. so maybe the
original gif is not perfectly centered
so it needed to be
um translated a little bit in order to
line up
yeah very good well so um beyond googly
eyes what other kind of
things would you maybe do uh jesse yeah
well
one idea was sunglasses add sunglasses
to people
um and then you mentioned like changing
uh iris color
yeah um you could do that just overlay a
small
small uh uh circle um
that's a translucent circle over the
uh or maybe you could do something with
you could if you were fancy with image
compose you could um
you could use a different blending mode
so that it would
um it would tint i guess just tint the
colored part without affecting the white
of the eye maybe
yeah i'm not sure something like that
that would be pretty
uh interesting and difficult i wonder if
you could do like um
what's what's that meme effect you see
the laser eyes you know
or you know an eye patch maybe yeah oh
avery is suggesting hats put a hat on
based on eye color
that would be cool you could um so like
add
a hat image to the person that's colored
based on the color of their
of their eyes okay so you could pull out
the um eye the left and right eye
centers and then maybe
offset just a little bit so that you get
the iris and then sample the color there
you could sample the color in a disk
maybe and take the average
just for for better accuracy make it
more robust
and then add a triangle or something um
on top of
on top of their head so let's see oh
it's 5 25
just as i looked at the clock so i'm
clicking the button i guess that says
time is up and we've we've got two
uh oh wait did i just see oh i just saw
some more come in
yeah we have one yeah matthew submitted
twice to try to make sure that he
beat the wire sure okay just in the nick
of time
let's take a look at uh let's take a
look at matthews let's let's do the
let's get the last one i presume it's
either a duplicate or it's the revised
one so okay
um we have this
image so find that a person who does not
exist
it's funny like you know maybe they do
exist they're just taking them off
linkedin or something
yeah maybe maybe it's a it's a the whole
thing is a sham
it's like a social experiment they've
just mechanical turked it you know
um but okay so some insert eyes thing
and maybe adding a wolfram thing in so
you know showing the company good points
for that
um okay look at that whoa nice
okay what is what are the eyes oh this
is rotated
what is it doing
hmm can you tell what it's doing from
the code
uh yeah we're getting the my best guess
is it's
translating it over it looks like but so
wait is a the um
the the our i uh
variable can you scroll up so i can see
the sorry i have the code on my screen i
don't need to bother you with that
um so yeah yeah so it's adding
um it's adjusting the position
it's adding a to both the x and or no
not x and y the
and x and y simultaneously so it's
moving it diagonally
well but wait is it x and y or is it it
looks like it's right eye and left eye
or i guess it's oh it's adding it to
them simultaneously because they're
lists okay
i get it i think they look to be moving
somewhat diagonally yeah you're right
okay i guess that's what's going on okay
okay let's um let's put that up for
voting we've got jonah ed
and let's say let's take jonah's second
as jonah's
real entry so jonah ed and matthew
and we've got a poll which i will go
vote on
okay let's take a look who is in the
lead
jonah is in the lead by the by a factor
of infinity oh
no longer now now now it's finite
in the lead yeah but not not by an
infinite factor
and um yeah we had this john a second
answer was this
uh googly eyed animation deal
that's awesome oh and uh indeed he
is a crowd favorite for the googly eyes
it looks like
um matthew
second
is not
right yes very good very good that gets
the uh
the pr points i'm sure danielle voted
for that one and then we have a static
ed submitted a static
googly eyes which is a honorable mention
for sure
uh jonah is uh pulling head quite a bit
but i mean if you can do an animated
googly eyes uh
i'm i'm satisfied this was a good answer
to the question so
danielle confirms that she voted for the
um
uh the wolf from eyes very good yeah bo
very good excellent and
we have just a couple seconds left so if
you have not cast your vote yet
cast your vote make your make your voice
heard
that's right in this democracy do you do
your duty
and uh vote for your civic duties that's
right
you're wolf from duty oh ed just gained
a vote
um but it looks pretty static at the
moment
so oh and jonah has won
congratulations jonah and matthew are
tied so let's see what that does to our
leaderboard
let us see absolutely um
by the way this is a cloud object so you
know definitely check out the wolfram
cloud it's pretty neat
yeah and live do cool stuff um
let's see jonah is in the lead two
points on top of ed
matthew and assad are now tied uh for
third
excellent great work jonah very good
very good okay shall we move on to
question
four we're looking at the time uh
fyi this will probably be the last
question unless we move on to a
tiebreaker
okay okay depending on how fast our
our contestants here yes if we get five
answers in like 30 seconds we'll
probably go into question
five we'll see we we shall see okay
um uh should we do we can skip the video
thing
um maybe we'll do that uh later okay uh
question four
is going live now and you should see
that in your
in your on your competitor devices
in momentarily okay there we go
countries create a chart or
visualization showing some property of
the countries of the european union
make sure to describe briefly in a
comment or text cell which properties
being shown
yeah you can use so you can use the eu
entity class so what does that mean an
entity class
it's not the list of the countries in
the european union but it's like a
a reference uh a reference to the the
group of entities the
class of entities that satisfy the
condition of being in the european union
so a really cool thing about that is if
you write your code to use
an entity class and get like values and
properties of entities through that
entity class then
if that entity class ever changes in the
future if a country enters or leaves the
european union as has happened
recently with the united kingdom um that
entity class like automatically updates
and the next time you run your code
you'll
you'll always have the uh the correct
correct data
used in your application if you're
basing stuff off of
entity classes and that i mean that
those that goes for entities in general
if you
write code that depends on the
population of uh
of france or the population of each
country in the european union
uh your code will always get the the
latest data that is available through
the
from knowledge base through that entity
so it's um it's
it's for a lot of applications it makes
a lot more sense than hard-coding
data values in your uh in your code or
in your
in some some data files locally
certainly
well what kind of properties do you
think they might want to uh visualize
i don't know let's take a look i think
there are quite a lot of properties on
um
on entity classes uh sorry on on country
uh entities
um so we could take we could take a look
at like um
uh yeah so let's do maybe we could try
out entity list of that
see what are the entities in that in
that entity uh
entity class there we go plot and world
map is a suggested thing that's neat
yeah oh wow it even
gives you like a little a little
manipulate you have to enable dynamic
uh let's just take a moment my poor
computer is running at max capacity
doing this video stuff yeah
yeah that probably cost us 2 battery
power right there no battery in the
reserve
so man it is a tough day to be my laptop
so that's all right keep your laptop
charged y'all
yep that is the lesson that is uh one of
the morals of today's
live event one of the many
life lessons to be extracted from this
glorious live event
absolutely many dozens surely um
this is not how long it takes to code
run this is a my machine kind of issue
at this point
sure can we take a look at the entity
list um uh
instead we could that could be cool
what we got going on here it's actually
i think it's probably not quitting it's
just a dynamic
oh maybe it was evaluating yeah um
oh you could do oh yeah okay that works
cool it's always
stunning to me to see just how many
properties we have i mean we probably
have some really obscure things about
really are really obscure cattle and
levels of minerals and sea water i mean
you name it we have
we have um can you delete the output
cell from the dynamic just in case
that's
the manipulate just in case it's uh
slowing it down
in fact i can i can get rid of uh
dynamic evaluation if that might
do the trick maybe it's the internet
thing
ah there was no issues before this you
know
but then the battery demon strikes the
internet one and yeah sure
soon my lights will flicker and um who
knows what
right but maybe you could try uh
quitting your
your kernel you might you might just be
stuck from that um
that manipulate that it's always the
saddest thing you know i don't want to
quit on it i believe in it
you know but sometimes it's necessary
sometimes and hey at least you can quit
the kernel separately and you keep the
because the notebook because the kernel
runs in a separate process so you can
quit the kernel um but you still have
your work and you can still save your
work so
i think that's a good design decision
having having those things separate
indeed uh would you perhaps like to
share this off well
this yeah sure i'd be happy to wonderful
okay so we've got question
four um so what we're doing we're doing
european union
okay so i might we can check the entity
list
what see what countries are in that i
wonder if there's a
this may or may not work um but i'm
wondering if i do dated of this
um and then like if i say i want the
european union
in 2007 is is that
uh no it gave it gave each of the
interesting it gave the dated versions
of each of those uh
um countries so i was i was wondering if
there's a way to get
like the european union as it existed in
2007 but
that may not be it may not be possible
at least not through entity classes
um but yeah we can do properties
as uh as robert was uh was
was uh trying to do and
okay there we go so there are a bunch of
these um
wow climate types electrical grid plug
plug images i think we had
a question in a previous live coding
competition that was based on that
if i recall correctly i know one was
written i don't know if it was actually
used it may have been a tiebreaker
but we had that at one point in a a life
coating competition so
let's see the plug images of each of the
countries in the european union
so this one this output is not going to
be uh like labeled
okay here we go eu standardization um uh
uh homogenization um uh we've got
almost all of the countries used i guess
that is the european
um uh uh plug
uh plug design cool and if we wanted to
see
which ones uh which uh countries use
which
plug we can do entity value which is
similar to what i did here with the
brackets that's the shorter form
but with entity value i can ask for the
entity association
an association of each entity to to its
value so
we've got cyprus ireland portugal
malta looks like are the ones that do
not use or do not exclusively use the um
the eu uh plug design i don't know if we
have any um
uh uh european uh uh competitors here
who
maybe from any of these countries who
can confirm but this is what uh
this is what the um these entities tell
us about the the
electrical grid plug images cool so
a whole bunch of properties i don't know
how many there are here
uh line 45 length 751
properties on country entities now bear
in mind not every entity will have all
of these properties available like we
might not know the
aggregate home value for householders
from 35 to 64 years old for
uh malta um but
many of these will be available for for
most if not all
um countries in the world
so you could we could just make a plot
maybe based on the electrical grid
plug images i'm not let's see
how would one do that it might be handy
or even a compatibility map
perhaps you do like a um a bar chart of
which ones are most common or something
um so that that's uh that's really
simple we don't care about which country
has which we can just
flatten all of these and
assuming that the images are identical i
can do
counts of this yeah they are okay so
uh so cool we just so we just did a
um count of which uh
counts of how many of each image appear
and since these all of these images are
exactly identical it was able to
to figure out the count of that um so
then we can do this
then what's a nice way to do
a a bar chart let's say
bar chart and there's some way to set
backgrounds for each bar i like that for
when you have images
so since i don't remember i can just
check the documentation and see that it
is
chart elements it looks like um so i
think what i want here is just
values of counts and plot the numbers
and then the chart elements are going to
be
the uh the keys which are those images
uh the keys in that association
there we go okay can't see all of those
but um
there's a bar chart of the electrical
grid
uh plugs in plug types
in the european union used in the
european union by
number so 25 of the standard one and
then three of that
sort of triangular curved one that's
used in cyprus ireland
uh malta and then two of this
other triangular curved one with a
different different blade uh
uh geometry so cool that's a that's
i think that's a pretty nice
visualization um now i'm sure
one of our content competitors was
working on exactly that and
now they're afraid that they can't
submit it because i just
did it and it will look like they stole
from me
and that's just sometimes that's how
life is i guess
um what what other stuff can we get out
of here interesting properties
uh attack helicopters is that like
number of attack helicopters
not just like regular helicopters but
attack helicopters
are there defense helicopters wow look
at that
it's okay there are numbers there there
you go
um uh who has the most that's that's
what i
i wonder um
so i should be using entity value to
begin with because it's
slightly quicker to switch over to
something else
but uh sort
estonia has zero australia lithuania
luxembourg sweden have zero
france has 293 attack helicopters
france is in the lead uh congratulations
i think
i guess that's something to uh to be
proud of
um and then i'm really i'm curious where
this data comes from so i was thinking i
could check the source
uh the source uh
qualifier ah no there's no source data
for that particular property
um often properties will have uh source
data
available but sometimes that's that's
not available either for
like like legal reasons or it just it
just isn't there and isn't available
in the system let's try another in this
case you know
we had to have spies sent out to each
other yeah absolutely yes this is this
is primary source
information the the wolfram wolfram
research um
intelligence office uh parachuted in
they used binoculars and they just
started
counting them recording tail numbers and
this is this is our numbers
exactly so we can't we can't give source
information to protect our agents in the
field
yeah just it just happens that way
sometimes adult populations we have
source okay here so this is the source
for it for each of those countries
we can see they all come from the world
factbook um
and we can even get information about
the source this is super meta
um i learned this recently because this
is actually a source entity
i believe um
yes so this is a source this the source
of this
entity's property or these entities
properties
um is another entity in and of itself so
it's the cia world factbook
um the question is how deep can we go
you know
how what what kind of facts i guess this
is the public version of the world
factbook but there's a url and i learned
this recently there's even a citation
which is awesome
this is there's actually a support page
on the wolfram website if you look for
it that
tells you if you want to cite data from
the wolfram knowledge base the first
thing to do is
check this source uh the source entity
um property qualifier
and then get the citation from here and
this is like a they
pre uh already formatted uh citation
that you can just drop into
any document that you're uh that you're
composing um
assuming it meets your uh your needs for
for citation formats
um so that's a really nice uh feature i
think
see full boundary length
interesting
classes that's interesting so we can see
what entity classes
is a given entity part of so if we grab
one of these
such as austria oh i see a solution came
in i will i will look at that in just a
second
austria what classes entered classes is
austria part of
oh a whole bunch of them african
development bank
um i guess that's not limited to
countries in africa maybe it's
countries who assist in development in
africa i don't know asian development
bank
australia group that is a lot of classes
any classes um
so so all of these just like european
union all of these are classes that
represent
uh groups of entities and are updated
live whenever the
like the real world constituent um uh
uh members of those those classes uh uh
are updated
so that's awesome okay let's check the
solution that came in this is from rule
oh okay something uh weird happened here
yeah this happens sometimes and i know
what the reason for this is um
one sec so
question four here let's delete all of
this
all of it okay so rules solution
actually the input came in as an image
um and this is just because the system
that we're using that we use to
collect these uh these solutions um it
will automatically convert the input to
an image if there are any dynamics in it
and there
it doesn't look like there are any
dynamics in here but this entity blob
with a check mark here
is actually a dynamic that check mark is
dynamic um
so uh this is actually short enough that
i can probably just retype it
uh real quick
so now that i've clicked that check mark
this is no longer dynamic and it's safe
to be sent so that's just a thing about
our
our system that's interesting
so is this properties without us a um
oh what happened to that i oh i deleted
it by mistake
so this is properties not as a string
but just as a symbol
but apparently actually it doesn't work
maybe it was a string on rule's end and
somehow got converted to a symbol
um in transmission i don't know how that
happened but here we'll convert it back
to the
uh there we go uh back to the
the string form so a random choice okay
so we're getting a any random and okay
any random property so random choice
um i think it's going to okay i see so
random choice is giving me
the entity property like fancy blob
here oh we have one more solution i'll
look at that in a second
and then just grabbing the um the string
the string name out of that another way
to do that would just be to get the
common name
of this uh this entity property
expression
um but last works uh works perfectly
fine as well for this case
so last and then
so okay hmm that's interesting what is
this about
uh entity
function so it's an entity function that
returns
both the entity and the property associ
the value of that property associated
with the
entity that's an interesting way to do
two things i suspect entity association
um might be a oh that's
okay so whatever property we picked here
i didn't see it um
there aren't any values available for it
um adjustment seasonal borrowings i have
no idea what that means
um electricity conventional thermal
there we go
um so this is an interesting way of
getting something kind of
kind of similar to what entity
association gives you
um so this is an entity function
that's like defining an ad hoc property
so instead of saying
our property is this this fixed one
electricity conventional thermal we're
saying it's a
computed property that's computed based
on this function
this function is given that entity as
input and the
value of this computed property is a
list containing the entity
and then um like the electricity
conventional thermal property of that
entity or whatever it was the one that
we picked
so that's an interesting interesting
approach to getting this data i bet we
could
uh alternatively just say uh
entity association here to get
uh oh no oops oops
um i meant to say okay prop
entity association there we go i was
just getting the association for every
single property instead of
this one so yeah now we've got an
association
and we could convert this to a list of
lists if we wanted by like saying
uh rule um applied at level one
to uh to
to this associate uh oh sorry not rule
yes
applied at level one converting from
rules to list
so um so that's a way to do it um
interesting actually that rule avoided
was this rule solution rule avoided the
potential solution that
uses rules in it um interesting
so put the entity function back
and uh last thing is geo region value
plot
so this is going to draw those countries
on the map they're polygons
oh we've got a third solution i'll get
to those in just a second
um
okay um and yeah it does look like the
strings got the quotes got cut off for
some reason
while sending this um
okay so uh so geo region value
what's that huh
um just see if you have a second
you're looking christopher posted okay
about giant eyes it is definitely worth
the time to look at it
is this sorry where is this uh in the
social
slack oh social slack okay um
for anyone watching the live coding
competition run this for some giant eyes
okay let's run it let's take a a
uh a diversion here
and run this code and see what it does
well wow that's computing oh there no no
result
i don't know what is going on here um
that's very interesting i want to take a
look at that later it might be like
just this property is causing an issue
i got it to work for me jesse so you
might have a typo in there
i might do you see a typo there might no
that's why i said might
okay mike sure um oh the only thing i
notice is you're missing semicolons
uh it shouldn't matter anyway yeah um
uh i mean here this one they're all
missing me
i must have made some mistake here um oh
wait what's this
oh yeah get rid of the prop there
which one uh right after your
european union uh right yeah i need
i need rules original code yep thank you
that was that was an edit that i had
made and then
left in thank you scott
downloading still not working probably
because these are missing so it doesn't
it doesn't really work all the time
because sometimes
um sometimes properties are missing oh
here's the giant eyes that's excellent
okay and i bet you could you could
modify this to do the uh cyclops idea we
were we were thinking of
um so okay cool so this is
trimming each each eye point making a
disc around it trimming the image to
that disc
and then probably scaling it up a little
bit and
uh insetting it back onto the image
overlaying it back onto the image um
using graphics awesome it's not as
jarring as you'd think
it actually yeah it looks looks pretty
good yeah and
here i'm i still hold out hope that i
can get this to work but i'll
let's go grab some of the other
solutions too
um there we go okay merchant ships
dead weight so dead weight i think is
that like before before the
the ship is loaded like it's um its
weight
just the the the uh structure of the of
the ship itself
i think that's the definition of dead
weight i don't really know
i am yeah i i should know this um i'll
have to go check the uh the star trek uh
next generation technical manual to see
the dead weight of the
enterprise d um so hold on this was
this was rule and this one
is jonah this is
so this is a bar chart radio stations
per mile of highway so
jonah has invented a new a new country
metric
you could do this using using an entity
function probably by the way to define
you could define an entity function that
is this property but this is a new
metric
number of radio stations per mile
of highway and it's not necessarily mild
because these are presumably quantities
that we get here so it's just gonna
it in fact it's probably mild for me
because i'm in the u.s so the
uh so mathematica is picking that unit
uh picking the imperial
unit um but i bet if you were in a uh
i think it chooses by default if you
were in a country that uh that uses
metric maybe you have to change that i
think that is a setting you have to
manually change but
we could anyways the point is we could
convert this to use any any uh
length unit we want so number of radio
stations
uh per mile highway has so many
has so few highways or it has so many
radio stations
that's a good question yeah czech
republic um
project republic which i can't spell um
i can spell czech but not republic
apparently um so let's see any radio
stations
i should run it i should run a spell
checker yeah
um a spell check that would be it
actually a spell check
so 352 rate that's that sounds like a
lot of radio stations
that's my guess for 200 yeah
it's very oh okay then it's actually
very little highway isn't it
um uh 205 miles is very little highway i
think
is that right to only 205 miles of
highway because in the us it's something
insane
um i don't know uh i
i think i looked at this recently i
don't remember what it is but it was
big
100 000 miles of highway that's actually
less than i was i was expecting but
still
um i guess they just don't have any
highways in the czech republic or maybe
they have road a lot of roads that are
not highways
i don't know um okay so that's that's
excellent so this is
uh just getting these this list of uh
quantities
of um reciprocal miles uh
is the uh unit here and then plotting
that
using bar chart um and then
labeling each bar with the which with
which uh country
it was awesome um
okay let's see third solution for here
uh
is i think that's that's assad right
of the answers i think his is the most
the most answer yes it is the most
answer
let's see notice the manipulating there
oh wow okay so what are we gonna see
this is like the maximalist answer
what is it doing let's see is it trying
to get like every
every property of every entity well it's
just those
fives oh yeah it is just five okay
it did take me a hot second for it to
actually work for me as well
sure yeah i mean one thing it's doing
here that is um
not totally efficient is that we're
mapping entity value across a list
and that's something that one generally
wants to avoid because entity value is
good
unless the value is cashed on your local
machine it's going to make a network
request
um or it may it's not it's not totally
like deterministic when it does or
doesn't but it it may make a network
request
so more um so this is going to make
however many countries are in the
european union that many
network requests while we could instead
write this entity value is listable so i
can give entity value you've seen me do
this before actually you've seen me give
it
either the list of entities or even just
the entity class itself
and then say i want this property um
from this and this is only going to make
a single uh network request
uh so much much faster much more
efficient so if you're
if you're ever writing code that is
mapping entity value
over a list of things it's not necessary
it's not certain that it's that it's
wrong or that there's a better way but
you should definitely check if there is
a better way because often there is not
always but
but often there is a better way um but
this is this is perfectly fine as a
certainly as a live coding solution um
uh
i don't know why that became aborted did
i abort it
no it happened to me too the initial one
i think just took too long but once you
click on any of them
they seem to work fine okay as long as
you don't re-evaluate well just in case
i'll rewrite this real quick
um uh to
maybe be faster yeah okay that seemed to
help
um so electricity from wind so it's
letting you pick any of these properties
and it's plotting it that's cool so you
don't even have to pick a property the
question said
some property assad said i can't decide
assad is indecisive so assad solution
lets you pick any property
that you want to see plotted or any of
the uh
five that assad thought were interesting
that's good so it's a curated selection
of interesting properties
and then from within those you can pick
awesome
very nice so full boundary length
okay yeah so someone who is that
hellenic republic wait what is that
where is that coming from
oh full name oh okay interesting
so that's the full name of uh greece
yeah actually called the olympics okay
and then federal
federal republic of germany okay for a
second i thought maybe these were like
names of historical countries but no
it's just the the full official name
i didn't even know we have that data
cool um
okay so assad and then we had one more
solution in and i think probably
[Music]
yeah probably time to close it after
after this one so if anyone gets a
solution in
in the next however long it takes me to
go over this one
uh then then your number five otherwise
we have four
so this is from matthew
and this is a pie chart of unemployment
rate that's an interesting uh property
um and oh we do have a number five
great so i will i will go ahead and
close this one
get the number five from ed
unemployment rate and then uh pie
charted oh and um
uh matthew took advantage of the fact
that you can say chart labels automatic
for pie chart
or many of the charting functions bar
chart i know does it other ones i think
um and it will take since this entity
association is an association
a pie chart is smart enough to say okay
each of these values are what i want to
plot in a slice of the pie and then the
keys are the names for those slices so
it's automatically assigning these uh
these labels here um based on the the
keys in the association
so unemployment rate um we can clearly
see spain
and greece are highest here i can't tell
what's smallest is that the czech
republic
in that slice maybe okay interesting
though unemployment rate that is a
interesting property to be plotting and
then finally ed
is uh letting you pick
looks like in principle any property
except there's actually only
what's this it's the missing seems like
georgian value plot does not like um
uh things with missing values well one
wonders how this ever worked then
um if it's fixed to be the the
population
property actually i'm i'm quite
surprised that we don't know the
population of some of these
that's is that really the case
no it's it is there what am i what am i
uh misunderstanding here
wait metric tons what
um
[Music]
i don't know why that's oh do i i
already have a
ah it's this eu variable that i had to
find from earlier
okay um so i don't know what eu was
what what ed was using maybe it was the
entity class here
but
okay cool there we go so yeah in
principle you can pick any property but
in reality it appears to be locked
population i could add another one in
here like
another death rate is that a thing i'm
just guessing
no okay that was a bad guess
birth rate
no okay i'm not good at guessing um
uh entity properties apparently but
anyways we can in principle pick any of
the properties listed in here and plot
it on a geo region value plot
okay so um i think now we can we can
open this up for
uh for votes thank you for your patience
avery we've got rule
jonah assad matthew matic
and ed uh so
rules is a um geo region value plot of a
random
uh property so is that that's
greece down there is that right my i
think that's greece yes
bunch of islands robert help me out here
he's gone
okay i hope i didn't just betray my i'm
sorry okay
uh i hope i didn't betray a uh my my
terrible knowledge of geography here i
think that is greece um
there's greece and concrete it looks
like history okay
yes so merchant ships deadweight that
makes sense a maritime country
um would have lots of merchant ships i
know a lot of a lot of
ships are registered is that ships red i
guess that ships registered in the
country
registered in greece regardless of where
in the world they operate
okay we've got jonah um
and uh which was this bar chart um
of radio stations per mile of highway i
really like that that metric there
um uh that should be built in i think i
think that really needs to be a built-in
entity property for country entities
assad which is a bar chart of uh
a property from assad's hand-picked list
of interesting properties
um food production per capita
interesting that that's
uh food production oh it's an index okay
so it's from
who knows how that's calculated it's
probably some uh i don't know
uh united nations something
um uh index but they're all
fairly uh close i wonder how you get
more than a hundred
on that index usually they're out of a
hundred and then mathematic
which is a pie chart uh of unemployment
rate
and ed is um is uh
population g region value plot or any
other uh
property you enter in there so it looks
like the pole is running down
i have to find the link because i don't
have it on this uh
on this machine i'll put it i'll put in
the slack
thank you much appreciated
oh well i can see on my other machine
that uh
that we have there we go paul thank you
um there we go jonah is the winner with
i believe that was
uh the uh miles of
radio stations per mile of highway
excellent
um and then assad and second matthew
rule and ed
great so let's see what that does to our
leaderboard that puts jonah
they've already been in first place but
jonah is in first place here
um and then we have ed uh assad
matthew rule and ubida awesome so
is six o'clock eastern right now so i
think that is
that is the end of of our event the end
of the line
um so i guess jonah wins
congratulations congratulations jonah do
you have any i will stop sharing do you
have any uh
uh any words um just to say
upon having won um
just wanted to say thank you to everyone
at the summer school
i walked in knowing basically nothing
but uh
after learning through all the lectures
and stuff i've gained a lot of knowledge
and so all of this is the culmination of
the knowledge of everyone at the wolfram
team so just wanted to say thank you
awesome awesome anyone else um uh among
the
the competitors uh have have any words
to say
well no i'd like to say thank you to oh
yeah robert of course i'm not a
competitor of course
um but uh y'all did great very
interesting and simulating answers and
this has been a lot of fun
and good job for putting yourself out
there and uh thank you to everyone
watching and hope it was entertaining so
see y'all soon congratulations okay
all right thanks for watching bye
everyone yep i think yeah
our viewers on twitch will get to see
the video one last time uh
before we end yes so bye everyone
thank you hi thanks for organizing and
congratulating you
thanks everyone
[Music]
you